en los comicios de este domingo en
argentina se renovará la mitad de la
cámara de diputados y un tercio de la de
senadores hay más de 34 millones de
personas habilitadas para votar lo harán
en unos 17.500 centros de votación en
todo el país que abrirán a las 8 de la
mañana y cerrarán a las 18 horas de
argentina para distribuir las más de 100
mil urnas en este territorio tan vasto
argentina es el octavo país más grande
del mundo con zonas muy remotas se
necesitaron 14 mil 70 vehículos que
incluyeron lanchas tractores y hasta
mulas se espera que los primeros
resultados de las elecciones se conozcan
unas pocas horas después del cierre de
los centros de votación
si los resultados de las primarias de
septiembre se repiten este domingo será
difícil para el gobierno de alberto
fernández y la coalición peronista al
frente de todos maniobrar en el congreso
podría perder el quórum propio en el
senado que preside la vicepresidenta
cristina fernández de kirchner y dejar
de ser la primera minoría en la cámara
baja- todo de cara a la segunda mitad
del mandato de alberto fernández cuando
el gobierno podría intentar avanzar con
medidas que no tengan que ver con la
emergencia de la pandemia en la que
debió concentrar sus primeros dos años
de gestión